let's go back into the 40s because
there's a lot of names when we go back
to the 40s
so my interest in the following is this
here's what my interest is
anybody that becomes a a high high level
criminal uh in any industry
saw it through somebody else typically
someone taught them how to do this yeah
it's not like they accidentally picked
us up somebody sought them how to do it
taught them how to do this
you know a few that maybe they're
inspired by a book they wrote a book
they read or a movie they watched but
for the most part they saw someone do it
so Epstein goes back Dalton brings them
in who who taught him the sex black male
model though you don't know that right
no it's very hard to know you know I
mean I'm sure there's some people who
claim they know but you know frankly
from what I've seen it's it's very hard
to know but I think it's more likely it
took place somewhere in the 1980s it was
probably either BCCI or even someone
like Adnan khashoggi right Adnan
khashoggi had a yacht and he would he
basically he was accused of having a
harem of women on that yacht and he
would use that to butter up
politicians private businessmen whoever
he needed to you know
help him accomplish his goals which you
know more often than I was you know
selling weapons weapons deals right so
um you know there's a lot of different
places that could have come from like I
mentioned earlier BCCI was sex
trafficking on basically an industrial
scale and as I note in the book the way
it's described what they were doing in
the BCCI report very similar to what
Jeffrey Epson and Elaine Maxwell later
did there was a woman he was working
with in that BCCI report on so this is
the the creator of um of BCCI and a
woman in in Pakistan because they were
trafficking women from Pakistan mainly
to the elites of the United Arab
Emirates it was probably more extensive
than that and it sort of acknowledged in
the BCCI report but what that report
documents is this Pakistan to UAE
pipeline
um and it's it's honestly very
disturbing but the way it describes what
this woman was doing in in advancing the
sex trafficking operation there very
similar to the Royal Galene Maxwell
would later go on to play with with
Jeffrey Epstein I have a question about
these women and I mean Yachts boats
women I mean I grew up in South Beach
this is every weekend right this is not
a big deal at all except for this so
women I mean there's no secret guys like
beautiful women I don't think that's a
controversial topic this is the tale as
old as time but these young women these
underage women my question is this is it
used for blackmail are they a pawn in a
deeper game or are they just sick [ __ ]
that actually like younger women meaning
oh I'm I'm into 15 16 year old girls or
no we're I'm into hot women you tell
them that they're 18 20 21 whatever well
it actually turned out she was 16 dude
and we have pictures to prove it and
we're going to use it as blackmail which
one is it I think it can be it really
depends it could be both really
depending on the person I mean look at
Jeffrey Epstein and Jeffrey Epstein's
case I think he was definitely doing the
gotcha stuff and the latter stuff to
people I think that's pretty clear but
in addition you know when he uh tried to
justify himself to journalist after his
first arrest he would be like now listen
historically the age of consent wasn't
16 and it's not that weird you know once
they hit puberty like game on basically
is what he was saying and people have
pointed to um I think it's an op-ed
piece that Island dershowitz wrote um
and I think the early 2000s or late 90s
don't know the exact date but he says
something like you know it should really
be once girls start menstruating Joshua
said this yes
this is why his name constantly gets
brought up you know um I you know
there's allegations against him
obviously but he's talked about it and
he's responded to it in interviews like
people have asked very direct about it
but I think that's part of his strategy
I think he feels like if he sharks away
from it people will assume guilt and I
think he thinks he has a better chance
of you know protecting his reputation if
he confronts it head-on but I don't you
know the court of public opinion as far
as dershowitz it's concerned I think a
lot of people seem to agree with the
allegations but again it's hard to know
you know when it comes to Epstein you
know if your name gets associated with
him even Epstein acknowledged in early
2019 you know he's radioactive is the
word he used to describe himself after
his first arrest so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]